the first thing that that point out is
here's all this information they provide
okay here's how far apart the particles
are so or they're starting points are
rather here's what we're going to use
for gravity today here's your first
particles details they don't tell you
the velocity of the second particle
that's because the question is you got
to wake up and then they tell you okay
at some point these particles are
actually going to collide which means i
can use this result that I just went to
all the efforts approved last time so
boxing on that and put a star on it
because then I can use it okay by the
way you do not have to obviously you
don't have to arrange it like this but I
like to do something like it
particularly you've got lots information
flying around so that number one you can
categorize it this is all the stuff of
our power cord this is all the stuff
about particle to etc and you don't lose
track of all the millions of equations
of monumental ok let's begin to solve
the first thing they want us to do part
one is work out it way is if the
particles do really Klein what is the
velocity of starting varsity of the
second particle and secondly I think
it's when to back alive that's the
question okay so have a look at
everything we've got on the board what
would you like me to do to try and find
v2 that's the starting velocity of the
second part we're done big oh yeah good
in part a we were 20 how to prove this
we'd be given V 1 theta 1 and theta 2 so
v2 is the lasting left there so this is
an obvious choice okay so i can say I'm
6 the particles collide
I'm going to quit this and pop all the
numbers that i don't i'm going to stick
them in so here we go 30 side of this I
don't know what V 2 years and then I'm
going to sign of that okay now what I'm
just going to evaluate everything what
is sine inverse sine of sine inverse of
four fifths it's just for Fitz by the
way what we were doing inverse trig we
had to do all this kind of fussing
around when we said oh yes I know sine
inverse of something it's not always
something you know we had to be careful
with that domain here why don't I have
to worry about that this person why
can't i just say for kids okay the
domain is being restricted because this
is a number it's not a variable right so
don't worry about our sign of sine
inverse of X is X sometimes look I've
got us I don't have a sometimes I've got
an actual number in there you could just
chuck that at your calculator if you
really wanted to it's just a number in
the same way I'm on v2 over here x 3
fits and if you solve your rearrange
divided three multiplied through you're
going to get for the second part was ok
well when does this happen when are they
actually going to collide now I'm
looking for it in other words i'm
looking for capital t remember I'd to
find that I said okay let's just define
let's just say there's sometimes here
where it happens and these are the
equations that I created okay now orange
is sold for capital T soft cuddly that's
what I laughter you remember we use this
equation in order to find me too so
therefore what seems to be the logical
choice if what I'm trying to solve for
now is capital T where are you going to
go
I've only got one equation that has
capital T left it right have a look down
on the board it's this guy it's this one
that we couldn't use before because I
didn't know the distance between the two
particles so you could do nothing to
resolve this right but now I no no no so
I'm going to come back to this in the
same way that I did it right here and
I'm going to evaluate everything here
and I should end up with these capital
tease be the things I did just solve for
ok Siri haunted house let's do some
substitution right since the particle
could collide I'm just going on with the
same line an argument not only is this
is true is this true which is everything
vertical ok that red box over there that
is also true because of what's happening
horizontally ok so I know all of these
pieces let's have a go they want is 30 I
don't know what T is i'm going to write
that down and then I've got cause of
this angle again so i'm just going to
substitute it in before I bother
evaluating it that's the left-hand side
ok the right-hand side I knew the value
maybe now I know its magnitude so that's
my 200 distance between the gym and then
i subtract ok I know what Vito is now I
just worked it out of line to go so 40t
cause of and then there's this slightly
different angle ok excellent now you
have a look at this we had a look at
questions like this right back early but
we had to do so mum in verse 3 some like
expansions and that kind of thing now
look at this guy which we want to try
and resolve ok cilan versus four and
five shiny must've fallen apart this is
an angle and it's it inhabits a
particular right angle triangle right
and in fact because you have a look this
is opposite on hypotenuse right you
could draw a diagram but come on we're
extension one students we know what the
last side in this triangle is right it's
clearly going to be three so this is 32
times this is just the other pair of
science the adjacent side which you just
told me is going to be three and there
hi ponch does that make sense if you get
to this point and either you have
Messier numbers or you're just okay I'm
in an exam panic I don't trust my own
instincts just go ahead draw the
triangle is fine and you'll find what
that last time that's the left-hand side
tell me what's right on the right time
okay not you've actually already
evaluated right so this in fact inhabits
the same triangle it's just i'm looking
at a different angle so this is going to
be forged okay now what was I trying to
do again what am i doing it is yeah I'm
solving for T yeah so I just have to
tidy this up a tiny bit what's the
three-fifths of 30 come on so if it's a
bird it's a team ranked 18 me can do
numbers okay four-fifths of 40-32 so
this is 200 take away 32 okay you have a
look how many T's you can get on that
left-hand side we chose oh that's going
to be 50 right so there you go I have a
time of collision after exactly four
seconds that's kind of neat isn't it
okay now somebody before well the people
who were here in the room and to have a
look at the rest of this question for
the rest of you who aren't quite there
yet what we want to do is and this is
question 13 in excess 3g we wanted there
for work out ok we know when they
collide I want to know where they
collide so where is this vertically
happening how far above half I rub this
horizontal axis am I like where am I and
secondly I'll read this for you you can
still a on it the second question is
what is the obtuse angle that's formed
between the two particles when they
combine okay so this is kind of just a
little variation on we can work out
impact angle and speed but now I've got
two things hitting each other right so
the angle between them is not going to
be measured from the horizontal they're
going to be measured between the two
particles okay so this is where we're
going to catch right so first thing
remember I said we just worked out where
the party when the particles collide so
how am I going to work out where they
happen
what am I going to do with this time
comes for I want to know where above the
axis so it's clearly a vertical thing
I'm interested in yeah now thankfully
for me I don't have to choose between
either these are two equations because
if they're colliding there should be the
same right so therefore I've got some
specific you let's continue so this is
part two when T equals four because now
I actually have a value for this choose
whichever one you want they're both the
same I'm going to go for y1 so I've got
a value for gravity so this is going to
be minus a half x 10 x 16 this is for
suede right so 16 good I've got a value
there and then I've got all this other
business over here right so I actually
know what all these things are there
already on the board right can I work
this up where is v 1 T sine theta 1 or
even just be one side than one where did
I wake it up x1 has been an issue
because they're in the room it was here
right do you remember remember when this
line come from this line came from v1
type in 1v 272 so that right there which
means that right there is v1 yeah sorry
1 sine theta work so I'm going to pop
that in that's four fifths of 30 which
is 24 right so this is what plus 24 x 4
because I actually have the particular
time right okay can you go ahead help me
out on the body
dad you man you jamaica jamaica to grow
yeah look okay this is 160 right you
haft it yes fourth 24 it's one lot of
for less than 25 Watts it for ya okay
okay you got calculators it's mine what
is me oh my god okay can we interpret
that where's this happening this is this
is 60 meters evolved whatever my ground
level was ok so there I am now as you
said all kinds of motion with its
straight-line motion simple harmonic or
projectile it's important to go from
numbers and actually make a statement so
I'm going to say therefore collision
occurs 16 that's not right wrong at this
up to us because 60 meters above this
ground level which we have to find if
they have to find rather as a bit